What if every customer message your business received got an instant intelligent reply,
even at 3 am, without you lifting a finger? That's exactly what I built with N-8N.
In this video I'm going to show you step by step how I built it from scratch,
every node, every configuration, every mistake I made along the way. My name is Sylvester.
Welcome to Sylvester's AI Lab, where we build real AI automations with not theory.
Most small businesses lose customers simply because they reply too slow.
Someone sends a message at 11 pm and gets a reply the next morning,
by then they've already gone to a competitor who responded faster.
The solution isn't hiring more staff. The solution is automation.
An AI agent that never sleeps, never misses a message, and knows when to escalate to a human.
Today we're building an AI customer support agent using N-8N and OpenAI.
It receives customer messages through a webhook, processes them through an AI agent,
detects sensitive requests like billing disputes or deletions,
sends an escalation alert to your email, and returns a clean response, all in under three seconds.
Before I show you how to build this let me show you what the finished product looks like in action.
I'm switching to my screen now to show you a live demo on my landing page.
Watch carefully. This is the exact workflow we're about to build together.